we were tired
we were scared felt at a loss it didn't
matter what you
what you were doing you were losing
people
you you had people crying saying just
let me die i don't want to be here
bridget could only watch in horror as
the virus spread
across the country a lifetime in care
work
but nothing could prepare her for the
devastation
that was to come we knew there was a
virus out there
everyone was ten on tender hooks because
we thought if it got in the home it
spread like wildfire which it did
didn't matter what you done or
how you tried to avoid it i mean we were
all
going by government guidelines wearing
ppe
and it was keeping people isolated
but obviously it got in
the virus infected the first residence
at the birchwood care home
in march it was just bedlam
um obviously people weren't coming in so
you sat
holding someone's hand um
and you go home in the evening and you
come back the next morning you've lost
three
the cruel solitary deaths one after
another
were taking their toll on bridget and
her colleagues
well we became like their family i mean
um some of us spent more to oh
sorry okay take your time
okay yeah
some of us spent more time at work than
we did at home
and we looked after those people as if
they
were our own one of our and it was
like losing one of your own i held their
round
i held their hand i'm not letting anyone
i careful die by themselves
the care home lost a quarter of its
residents
13 vulnerable lives taken by the
pandemic
caring for three three gentlemen
who were or seriously
seriously very very poorly
um
to listen to someone choking
you know clearing their throats and
being hot delirious
crying
and then coming back the next morning
and all three
gone
that sense of grief being felt by
bridget will be shared by
the colleagues and staff who work with
her here at
birchwood but the sense of loss
will be felt in care homes right
across the country
bridget is brave to share her pain with
us
we can begin to understand the trauma
being suffered by carers everywhere
but she's terrified she may have to
relive
her ordeal you're scarred
and scared because there's another one
coming
we're better prepared but it's
my job my job is caring for people
and that's what i do ashish joshi
sky news